ciao
[Music]
thank you president honourable members
the coronavirus pandemic continues to
create
extraordinary challenges for our
societies
as we emerge from the height of the
health crisis
we now face a different yet pressing
task
creating the conditions for a successful
economic and social
recovery we need to support the sectors
and regions most affected by the
pandemic to kick-start
the economy and lay the ground for
sustainable recovery
across europe yet we also need to ensure
that
other vital priorities for our union
such as green and digital transition
are met and matched by the rate bright
resources
that is why the eu recovery plan
represented by the commission
at the end of may is so important and
why it will be the main focus of our
efforts in the weeks ahead
we are called to agree shortly not only
on the instruments of the recovery
but on the entire multi-annual financial
framework for the coming years
and this is no small task the council
and the european council
are fully mobilized behind these common
efforts
members of the european council will
hold an orientation debate
on the eu recovery package on friday
through video conference the president
of the european council wants to give
leaders
an opportunity to discuss the various
aspects of the overall packages
and prepare the subsequent summit which
should
if possible be a physical meeting
while the president of the european
council launched the political
consultations
at the highest level following the
commission's proposal
we also immediately started working the
council
the croatian presidency has organized a
series of meetings
both the technical and political levels
in
order for the delegates to closely
examine and present
their views on building blocks of the
package
this technical and political work on the
proposals
is needed to pave the way for the
leaders discussion
these discussions in the council have
helped clarify
many issues and were held in a positive
atmosphere
delegations are willing to look at the
both the mff
and the recovery plan as a package
taking into account
the effectiveness of this crisis
continuous cooperation with the european
parliament
will remain crucial if we want the
package to enter into force already in
january
2021 the ambition is for the european
council
to provide its political guidance to the
council before
summer break which would allow us to
promptly seek the european parliament's
consent
let us be honest this is a very
ambitious approach
but these positions are still a part on
a number of issues
but together we have to make sure and to
do
outmost so that mff and the recovery
instrument
swiftly bring tangible positive effects
for our citizens
and businesses while the eu recovery
package
will be the main focus of the leaders
discussions on friday
they will also touch upon other issues
in particularly
let me know that president michelle will
update the leaders
on the state of play of the eu uk
negotiations
on the future partnership unfortunately
so far
we didn't achieve as much as we hoped
for
that is the case in all four crucial
areas
level playing field fisheries governance
and internal security
as well as foreign policy and external
security
to which you rightly devote a section in
your recommendation
since the uk government has confirmed
that they will not consider
an extension of a transition period what
is ahead of us
is about four months of further
negotiation
taking into account that time necessary
for a proper ratification process
the fact that we are left with so little
time is not
the choice of the council nor of the
parliament but we have to respect it
the mandate and political declaration
that are guiding
our negotiator as well as the resolution
of the subject
are anchored into the situation created
by the united kingdom
the uk has a choice either to preserve
enough alignment
with the union and retain sustain
substantial access to the single market
or
choose its own path not only in terms of
sovereignty
but also in regulatory terms which would
reduce the scope and the depth
of the partnership that can be concluded
we believe that a negotiating mandate
adopted by the council
last february and largely echoed by your
resolution provides for enough
flexibility to find an agreement
in a little time left this is also why
we support the decision of the
negotiators
to intensify the pace of negotiations
over the summer
so that by october we can see a draft
partnership emerging
before i conclude let me finally stress
that as
also pointed out in your draft
recommendation
we have causes for concern in the
current implementation of the withdrawal
agreement
needless to say progress in the
partnership negotiations has to go hand
in hand
with progress in the implementation of
the withdrawal agreement
thank you very much
thank you mr president honorable members
the
negotiations with the united kingdom
always promised
to be difficult and they have not
disappointed
monday president sasoli president
michelle
and i discussed the way forward with
prime minister johnson
the prime minister confirmed that he
does not want to extend the transition
period
beyond the end of this year we on our
side
have always been ready to grant
extension
but it needs two to tango and this means
that we are now halfway through these
negotiations with five
months left to go but we're definitely
not halfway through the work to reach an
agreement
with little time ahead of us we will do
all in our power to reach an agreement
we will be constructive as we've always
been
and we're ready to be creative to find
common ground where there
even seems to be none what we are not
ready to do is to put into question
our principles and the integrity of our
union
because it is our duty to protect the
interests of the european citizens
michel bernier who has done an
outstanding jobs over
the last month michel barnier has
explained many times
why the four outstanding issues are so
crucial
first of all the level playing field the
fundamental issue at stake here is
fair competition we're ready and willing
to compete with british firms they're
excellent and
our firms are excellent too but it
cannot be a downward
competition just think of labor
standards or environmental protection
it should be a shared interest for the
european union and the uk
to never slide backwards and always
advance together towards higher
standards
second on fisheries no question
the uk's no one question the uk's
sovereignty
in its own waters without any question
but we ask predictability and we ask for
guarantees for our fishermen and fisher
women
who have been sailing in those watches
for decades
it is very clear that there cannot be a
comprehensive trade agreement without
fisheries
without a level playing field or without
strong government's
governance mechanisms governance
governance may sound like an issue for
bureaucrats
it's not it is central for our
businesses and our
private citizens both in the uk and in
the european union
it is crucial to ensure that what has
been agreed
is actually done and finally on police
and judicial cooperation
we want our citizens liberties
fundamental rights
and data to be safeguarded in all
circumstances
and this is why we expect a role for the
european court
of justice where it matters
these are objectives not only in our
discussions with the uk
but in any relationship with
any partner because these are principles
at the heart of the european union fair
competition
rising social standards the protection
of our citizens and the rule of law
this is who we are and it is not
going to change honourable members
i'm particularly glad for the
unity that all institutions have shown
and for this parliament's full support
throughout this process
this will even be more important than
the next phase of
the talks no one can say with certainty
where these negotiations will be at the
end of the year
but i know for sure that we will have
done
everything to reach an agreement and to
have a good start with the uk
as a third country neighbor
parliament
[Music]
a